thank you
foreign
guys before we start many of you will
know that there's been some devastating
natural disasters that have been taking
place
Morocco and one in Libya I've seen some
of the scenes some of the videos
honestly they're heart-wrenching
heartbreaking things to watch I can't
even watch them that's how bad it is but
we have a responsibility upon us I have
responsibility and you guys have a
responsibility what kind of people would
we be if we just watch something like
that and we have the capability it will
take us seconds yes seconds to make a
massive contribution to the victims of
such disasters and we decide not to I'll
leave links in the description below
please find it within your heart to not
only give charity but to make Dua for
the victims or of this natural resource
let's start off with um and this is
again with the permission of Patrick and
David he we're not going and having a
meeting and then talking about privacy
things that were discussed we had a
prior we didn't start off as a private
meeting between myself you're yourself
and him and another individual Robert
there and from there we concluded at the
end we had some good things it was a
very great positive meeting and he said
go ahead and discuss some of the things
that we talked about with his permission
so where would you like to begin well I
mean let's begin with uh you know what
happened exactly so many people would
have seen the video where I mean Ali
dawa are basically talking about this
negotiation that took place and it was
weeks and weeks long these negotiations
between us and valutainment relating to
a debate between us and some
interlocutors about in the first
instance about Judaism Christianity in
Islam so we agreed to such encounter and
discussion but then there were some some
problems let's say in this in the
negotiations in the boundaries settings
uh between us and uh and the other party
and we felt like the kind of deal that
we were getting was a rule one and so we
decided uh to uh to move away from it
all together because we thought that you
know for example we had uh inequality in
the numbers of people that were going to
be representing Muslims comparative to
the amount of Christians that were going
to be there if we include the host and
the co-hosts and stuff like that we had
a topic which wasn't set and uh was yet
to be set there wasn't even a guarantee
of equality of timing which is standard
in professional debates and stuff like
that and we kept asking some of these
questions and we didn't get a
satisfactory response and so because we
we felt more and more uh frustrated by
the whole experience we decided to bring
the matter to the public
and you know because of that and other
things we decided to speak to Patrick uh
face to face about on Zoom review of
course as a moderator and I think that
was your initiative and you should be
giving credit for that
um yeah because I think you see things
that we don't see obviously being in
America haven't spoken to him haven't
had private conversations with him and
to be honest with you in that
conversation he came across as extremely
facilitating he came across extremely
humble
and a generous magnanimous
and so if anyone shows us that level of
energy I think it's only right for us to
respond in kind and he was very
concessionary in fact saying that uh you
know all of those aspects that we've
spoken about the topic can include both
Christianity and Islam that there will
be a co-host and that you would be the
co-host so it would be instead of
Patrick David being uh the only person
to host it it would be you and Patrick
but David which would be which would
kind of distribute uh the bias if you
like and create more of a an equal
playing field as it were and uh
critically as well that we could
actually use the footage for our own
social media platforms and so there we
could potentially uh you know put it on
our our channels which which would
increase the obviously the region and
would be better for everybody as well
and uh this would prevent any potential
Distortion that could happen uh is that
you know in the potential debate which
we don't think that Patrick would go
that far and do to be honest based on
the conversations we've had with him and
based on his track record they've been
distort especially considering the fact
that he actually did in the first
instance actually say that it was going
to be live anyway so that was a
mitigation that we we put in place in
the first instance but with all those
things having been said uh it sounded
much more agreeable frankly uh and if in
fact by the end of the conversation we
had a broader conversation about Muslim
Christian interlocutors where uh we we
suggested William Lane Craig
and Ben Shapiro and he has links uh to
Ben Shapiro has just been on his show uh
and as many people will know I've had
many videos uh you know refuting Ben
Shapiro and his Palestine issue on on
the Palestine issue and so on so that
would be a massive you know kind of
debate if you like or discussion that
could potentially happen along the line
as well so there's there's good to come
out of this but since we're still in the
kind of negotiation stage and we're
solidifying everything and there's a few
things we have to take care of from our
perspective in the United Kingdom uh we
we cannot update the public with an
exact date and time as to when uh the
engagement will take place with whom and
what topic would be or whatever until
all these things are set in stone but
the the point to be noted here is the
point to be noted here is that quite
frankly he was facilitating and it does
seem like Patrick David and
valuetainment want to go more in a
direction uh of Building Bridges with
the Muslim Community tackling some of
these issues uh for example the issues
to do with transgender ideology uh and
uh you know teaching LGBT curricula to
Children uh and things like that which
everyone let's call it more to say
conservative because we're not
conservative from a ideological
perspective but certainly we're
traditionalists and we align more on
those issues with U.S conservatives than
we would do with liberals agree on so
that's really the gist of the music of
the productive meeting a fruitful one at
that and it's only fair just as we came
out in public to reprimand and to
criticize Patrick Davis for us to come
out and do the same thing uh when he's
being so concessionary with us
you know a lot of people when you look
at that that that's the honorable thing
to do and that's what we're called to do
as Muslims I mean that's you know that's
something that now obviously anyone
who's extended we've I and I've
commended him actually and I've seen his
progression he's come a long way from
years ago some things that he said and
then we've also respectfully you know
presented the arguments academically
I've gone and we made some videos and
then you've have also and I think that
things are starting to turn for the
better compared to like Joe Rogan now
you remember me and you I think we've
addressed some things to Joe Rogan yeah
me and you as a programs and Joe Rogan
it looks like he really did a turn it's
one of the most popular religions in the
world but it's also it's a religion that
Embraces discipline you go through
Ramadan you're not eating all day you're
not drinking any water all day that
belief system helps people remember he
was having a lot of islamophobes and he
was just really one-sided but him also
he was been talking recently you've done
some videos on that and we give credit
where credit is due because we're not
trying to remain in some hostile
environment I mean of course we're going
to call people out for the mistakes
their blunders or we've tried to do it
in a respectful manner hoping that the
door is open that if the people want to
come respectfully and sit with us talk
with us not just talk about us talk with
us and we're have a seat at the table
and I think this is going towards that
path for the greater good the greater
picture you know and the public may not
know that there was a time where Joe
Rogan was actually on his show and he
had a a particular t-shirt on which had
the word redovic on it is it redovic
right you remember yes yes and I thought
to myself this looks unbelievable what
why is this familiar and I realized wait
Eddie redovic so he had your surname
that was my last name why did he so tell
me why did he have your surname on his
T-shirt
I was just wondering I said look how
Allah God Almighty these are like signs
it's a sign for him I don't know he had
he had literally he had like my that was
from my school he had my my rhizovic Jiu
Jitsu t-shirt on his uh report we
pointed that out we got some uh we had
some Jiu Jitsu going and we got some
nutrition here you're not the only one I
mean well I'm not the only fan of your
Jiu Jitsu oh yeah yeah I'm not the only
fan of your Jujitsu because I mean uh
we've got someone who's actually of note
who is wearing your T-shirt I mean let's
take a look at this
oh
hey that that's our buddy we were
actually that's uh our friend Joe Rogan
that's your T-shirt though isn't it yeah
that is uh our t-shirt yeah that's your
surname on that that's my surname in in
uh yeah that's my last name because you
made a video right with one of the uh
with one of them before about about
um Joe Rogan some of his
um some of the things that he said about
Islam yeah what do you think this is a
kind of peace offering or what is this I
don't know I think you know like I like
I mentioned in the video we did yeah we
really wanted to reach out to Joe yeah
yeah in a benign a nice kind way that
shows you something very important which
is that the work that you're doing at
the dean show and the work that's being
done in terms of trying to to put our to
kind of put our two cents if you're like
in the narrative it's having such an
impact that someone like Joe Rogan who's
considered to be like the top podcaster
maybe in the United States maybe one of
the top leading ones in English-speaking
world
uh that he's actually putting your
t-shirt on I think it's to be honest I
think it's a sign of respect I think
he's done that because he's seen your
videos he's clearly seen our videos
together that what we've put forward and
he's put that on to show look we're not
against each other I think he's done
that as a sign of respect and he also
respects the fact that you're also a
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu practitioner people
don't know about you you I don't know
how many stripes you've got now on black
belt is it five stripe four stripes or
four degrees yes which is for those who
don't know that is it takes years and
years and years to achieve that that is
you know that takes more than 10 years
to achieve for the average person maybe
12 13 years and so he respects that
because he's a black belt himself and he
sees a Muslim and he sees many Muslims
like yourself in the UFC and so on
coming on um he's coming on and speaking
about his religion in a very respectful
way
which shows you that your approach has
reached the highest levels uh Eddie
which is something you should be really
proud of alhamdulillah
accept it from you from me from all of
us and continue to bless his work and
tell me so you being now in a position
where we've come a long way having this
emergency meeting and now some of these
names that you mentioned hopefully
they'll put this together why is this
important why is this and how is this
something this is historic I think it is
and you were mentioning you were
mentioning you were mentioning like if
you look down 50 years you said
something brilliant and people are not
looking you know ahead if you want to
look 50 years repeat what you were
saying that's very important nowadays if
you look at what what teenagers study in
secondary schools they study the civil
rights movement because there was some
Paradigm shifting cultural moments you
know this study what happened with
African Americans the study feminism
they study all these kind of things that
happened in 96 in particular yes those
legislators have changed but there was
also a Grassroots movement which was
important enough to be studied 50 to 60
70 years later
I think what we're seeing with the
cultural Wars uh nowadays is significant
enough to be a historical event and I
think that because of social media we as
the Muslims do have now a voice in that
particular historical moment and people
are going to be studying that I do
believe that people could be studying
this 56 years from now it is
historically significant as all those
things that were happening at that time
because quite frankly it's even more
watched it's even more popular pound for
pound you know then those things were at
that time the only thing that's not
there is legislative change but I think
it's as historically significant of
what's going on in the 1960s and so
people will be looking at figures like
Joe Rogan and studying them I think 60
years from now potentially figures like
Patrick David and I said that to him I
said that people were looking at
valuetainment doing courseworks and
studies and Theses about what was said
what was their stance with Muslims or
what was their stance of Jews and was
there yeah what was their sons of
Christians and and so on and so forth
these things are very important now it
constitutes the Legacy the cultural
Legacy of the history really the the
sociological History of the United
States of America
and the Western General and we have a
place in the on the table as you've
mentioned and and said as the Muslim so
we have to be careful how we strategize
so that we don't agree to everything and
we don't disagree to everything we we
bring ourselves a favorable result which
means that we need to be wise with these
things and I think having this emergency
meeting with Patrick David was the wise
thing to do and his response was in turn
the wise response I think he's a very
pragmatic person and you can't be that
successful in business as he is and have
you know an Empire of valuetainment or
whatever unless you are pragmatic like
that so I think the more we think about
the collective interest the more things
are going to go right for everybody
I like uh and it made sense on both
sides this is why this meeting was so
important having this meeting now we can
see like what the way you were
presenting everything and then he was
also he got into his very transparent he
was showing his emails how he gets
things you know the short amount of time
this that and the other and you're
really not knowing on one end who this
person the other these islamophobes
career islamophobe and then you also you
know now it's coming down to
the the time that you gotta you you need
to know like what's going on so you can
better prepare you so you can see things
you know from both sides and then at the
end and just coming together because
these people that were lined up I mean
these are these are career islamophobes
these were people with blood on their
hands these are people who now you had
uh you know the Andrew brevik was it I'm
there and he was mentioned in his Anders
brevik in his Manifesto was mentioned
these people so this was very sensitive
also now that you I mean this is not a
problem for you at the end this is
something that's your specialty and
you've dealt with people like this but
um it was nice to see how he had
presented things you could see where he
was coming from you and then how
everything just at the end it came out
to a positive ending what were your
thoughts about that absolutely and I
think I mean the way he presented it was
that he had no idea
um who these people were and I have
reason good reason to believe that
especially in the second person who's
Rashid a hamimi he wouldn't know who he
was because most of his content is in
the Arabic language so that unless you
have access to that I fair play you
won't know who he is but these people
have had strong anti-islamic sentiments
and they you know they attack the
prophet of Islam not just that not not
just the fact that they attacked the
prophet of Islam and Muslim people but
they they effectively try and make life
harder for Muslim people in the west I
mean some of the organizations and what
they're dealing with they are making
things harder for Muslims in the west
and in a way we can't really deal with
that and it's imagine having a you know
a podcast where the premise of it is to
try and create Bridges and you bring
people who frankly are trying to break
all bridges I mean these people who have
no interest in collaborating with Muslim
people uh it was it was a bit kind of
off-key from that perspective but I
think the fact that we explained to him
who these people were
he understood at least where we were
coming from you know why why would a
Muslim in the first instance be angry
that you've invited these two people and
then you've invited then you've done
these kind of things and then certain
particulars were not very clear
it just added to the frustration but he
was very understanding and we appreciate
that and that's uh where it needs to be
is a good negotiator and I have to give
him credit where credit is due
and you see that at the same time before
that he was uh talking about he had
Candace Owens on you heard of Candace
Owens and every time I see many of these
conservatives Christians come out and
they talk about you would think she's
almost she's talking to in a way that
for instance she was talking about the
and this goes in Under the Umbrella of
things that we have in common that we
can talk about and you invite us to the
table to talk about these things see the
Muslim perspective she was talking about
the Demonic culture now that's affecting
the youth the over sexualization of
children I'm sure your brain you're like
man you got a lot to we got a lot to say
on this right those women of selling
themselves only fans Instagram they're
just out there but they're just naked
and looking at the Kim Kardashian's
others as role models and how she was a
part of that lifestyle but she changed
for the better the fem the feminism and
the uh demasculation of men uh the the
mother being looked down instead of like
a home engineer you know choosing and
she was actually asked on his program
what would you rather be a career woman
or a home engineer they say home
engineer I call it a home engineer or a
mother and she said a mother and then
she talked about so many of these things
that we we just we're on board with what
would you say absolutely and that's what
we should be looking for we we should be
I mean the Quran instructs us
effectively to look for common ground I
mean the most common of grounds we
should be looking obviously still hate
monotheism from a theological
perspective and try and draw conclusions
from that
um but these things are also things
which are commonalities between Islam
and let's say Christianity or
traditional versions of it and at the
end of the day I mean there's there's
work to be done here I think that we
have kind of neglected the conservative
community in the west we've neglected
them in the dawa in a way which isn't
really I think justifiable we need to
look at them as individuals who can
contribute and we can contribute to them
because I think that from a dialogue
perspective from from a evangelizing
perspective we can bring a lot of them
to our side in fact by just explaining
to them that these are the ways that we
live a lot of people become Muslim just
by looking at how we as Muslims live our
lives so I think there's a lot of work
to be done